congratulations we've known each other
for a while but congratulations on on
big mouth it is hilarious
thank you for hilarious show it's really
funny the jokes are amazing animations
terrific the voices are great but what I
really like is that you guys are
addressing you men and women that work
on the show are addressing these very
very uncomfortable aspects of puberty
mm-hm that a lot of people are afraid to
talk about and you use a lot of
autobiographical stuff from your life
which I would be afraid to talk about
like you talk about your first kiss show
I do
yeah the my first kiss in real life was
a truth or dare on the back of a bus and
then we did a version of it why is that
funny
it was a public bus you mean you didn't
rent a bus just for the occasion I got a
one I got a party bus me and this girl
had a crush on no and we yeah I made out
with her and I was terrible at it and I
like you don't know it I jammed my
tongue down her throat and just got a
circled her mouth and I had it was there
I had enthusiastic consent but but it
was terrible and I now know she let you
know they let me know it was terrible
and I've since spent many years being
like yes that's fair yeah I was terrible
yeah it's probably on some level this
might be like good therapy for you that
you've made this show where you can
you're very open about these humiliating
experience yeah I mean it's like there's
a lot of it about Nick having a little
penis on the show and notice your hands
covered your crotch yeah as you said
that
I know I want everybody to know that it
is now completely average yeah one sick
sweet for each so but it is it's weirdly
but I have to say it's very um there's
something cathartic about it because the
stuff that happens to you when you're
going through puberty then kind of
affects you for the rest of your life I
don't think I mean you I don't think you
guys were eat have you been affected by
what happened you during puberty at all
my puberty was so recent it was during
Obama's second did you finally felt
comfortably the voice dropped and things
started working but no I think yeah I
wish that a show like this that existed
it couldn't have existed back in the
1970s when I was in you know late 70s
when I was a teenager early eighties it
couldn't have because that you couldn't
get something like this on TV but it
would have made me feel better
about awkward thing yeah I think it is
part part of what I like about the show
is that it's it's an opportunity I think
puberty you feel so isolated and like
you're the only one going through it and
the crazy things that are happening in
your body that you see a show where
people are talking about that it
happened it's happening to them or it
happened to them or like you know people
come up to me on the street and talk to
me about all kinds of stuff that that
happen to them let's be fair that was
happening before the show come here
let's talk about
[Laughter]
[Applause]
okay